I'd seen all these negative things ain't
oh if your trump supporter you're a Nazi
you're this you're that and I'm not
those things I love my country I love my
president I disagree because I have
literally gotten death threats for
expressing my public opinion on politics
on support of the president I mean I'm
not gonna stop expressing my opinion but
I still disagree that I feel safe doing
so I think most Americans don't at this
time I do not believe that suppressing
my opinions from people does anything
good for the for the betterment of
society but as member of the LGBT
community it's pretty hard to hold those
views and I just purposefully make a
decision that I'm gonna be responsible
for my own safety and I don't let
anybody intimidate me that way for me
I'm a skateboarder and an industry that
is pretty much dominantly liberal where
the graphics are Trump shaking hands
with the KKK I've been spit on before
I've been cursed at I've had my board
tried to be broken from skateboarders
even though I don't feel safe wearing it
publicly I will continue to do so
because I will not have my voice
silenced
I somewhat agree that they're not
important let me tell you let me explain
why because the same issues of the black
community affect all communities and if
we are Americans if we truly consider
ourselves Americans my issues are no
different from his issue or her issues
or her issues or her issues or his
issues whether you're white or black or
brown or green I'm gonna say I strongly
disagree and all due respect I disagree
because there are different issues in
the black community than are in other
communities there's higher crime rates
there's higher abortion rates there's
crime and violence within this community
there's a lot of hatred within my
community being black against police
officers and those are specific to the
black community that is a very good
point but we as Americans of whether
you're black brown or white you have a
certain obligation of the civil society
so I have the obligation to stop when
the police officer says stop so I'm
giving that as an example which has
happened in many cases at where abuse
has followed because the black runs and
he fights back I agree with that but
what you just said you took 20 seconds
to explain a black issue so it is a
problem but of course everyone is
responsible for that problem but this
community is hurting and they're just as
American as everybody else
[Music]
I strongly agree that we need the wall
it's not a matter of racial issues but
national security let me say that first
first off one out of every three
illegals comes with a federal crime
whether it's murder or rape or even drug
cartel also we talked about black issues
what about the illegal immigrants that
come that are dreamers what about the
American black dreamer the his dream to
be a lawyer
his dream to go to college and his
dreams have become something and get out
the hood but sadly we allow these
illegals to one past those who are
waiting for a long time to legally come
to the country because there is a
difference and it's almost a slap in the
face I do know at my school it's a
public university they give out free
college to undocumented students yeah
Here I am
I come from a middle class family but I
don't get any scholarships like I get
very little I can barely afford college
yet these people who aren't even US
citizens they get all these benefits
that I myself as an American citizen
can't get I somewhat agree to this I
think the wall is is useful and
essential but the real issue is what can
we do to make our country have him an
easier system for people to come in in a
legal fashion
it's the procedure that is too difficult
too long too cumbersome we would love to
have them come in they benefit us they
help us to grow they provide new ideas
but let's be rational about this and to
keep it equal with the citizens of this
country who already here
I guess the reason why I somewhat agree
it depends what you mean by support if
anyone dares to mess with her I'm gonna
kick their ass so like she's got my
support a hundred percent but if you're
asking me as a Christian I'm gonna loves
them and matter what they are we're all
like I said it's an American issue and
we're all posed to give this together if
it's contrary to natural law which it is
in my view then I don't agree with it
however I can like you as a person with
the LGBT community that is in pretty
much has morphed into a gay rights
organization so they fight for rights
that are outside of the natural rights
of the Declaration of Independence life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
within the boundaries of natural law so
that's why I don't support the LGBT
community in their activism but I do
support them as individual human beings
with the same rights as I have no extra
rights no extra right to marry same sex
but the same right as I have but you but
you're right say you can marry whoever
you want oh very good okay good point
good there are a lot of features in the
LGBT community they're a little bit hard
to deal with I don't identify with a lot
of those people I identify as a
transgender person not necessarily as a
gay or lesbian person my wife on the
other hand all of a sudden found herself
in a same-sex marriage if it's not
something that she signed up for
same-sex marriage is a different thing
but who cares who you love I'm very
active in the Republican Party and I'm
trying to make a big inroads with the
religious freedom and the super
conservative religious people because
they need to learn to deal with me
because I'm gonna I'm not going anywhere
you know you live your life you doesn't
agree with my life I shouldn't feel
compelled to affect your life because I
don't agree with it
oh yeah finally get a lot of flack for
this I strongly agree he's strong and he
is fighting for Americans he listens to
what we want and yeah he doesn't always
tweet the best stuff but I mean
everybody's done that but the fact that
matters he has principles and now he's
standing for what he believes in and
he's taking us to the future is safer
better stronger America for all of us a
reason why summit agrees because I don't
think any president should be a role
model for children I think they should
be a role model for American like
American men and grown adults so I don't
think Trump should be a role model for
children because if so he had to be PC
all the damn time
which does nothing but hurt Americans
he's the old school to tell you straight
up to your face the doctor that tells
you this year if he tells you gotta lose
100 pounds and stop smoking your old eye
you get mad you might get insulted but
you find out he's only one telling you
the truth I somewhat agree as well
because I think that he's a good role
model because he sets out what he's
going to do and then he goes and does it
and he's also a good role model because
of some of the things he says which is
not acceptable and that is what real
life is about it's not that somebody is
perfect and never makes a mistake people
make mistakes they repent from their
mistakes and they go out and do
something positive
I did lose a couple friends I went to
school with the Trump shirt on and I
brought a Trump flag and waved it around
I had a couple of teachers get really
mad at me and that may have affected my
grades at the end of the year even
though I lost some relationships I've
built
really good friends I just really get
along with people who think similar to
me or accept what I think they don't
have to agree with me but if you're in a
community where people can accept you
for who you are those are the true
people you need to surround yourself in
I mean I lost friends family members
supporters business associates when I
came out for Donald Trump in 2017
February at the Grammys I wore a dress
that said make America great again so I
knew I would you know create a stir but
hitting number one on iTunes Amazon
billboard my album rose to number one
because of Trump supporters so I've lost
things but I've also maintained this new
community based on who I truly am you
know any relationship that you lose as a
result of supporting Trump is no real
relationship anyway because he's only
there temporarily I mean this is what
everybody keeps forgetting I mean this
guy is only gonna be here for what
another four or five years and so I want
to remind everybody of that you know
it's not the end of the world not yet
it's getting there but not yet
[Music]
all right it's kind of easy
oh come on you can get over here I
strongly agree there's some issues the
man has got some idiosyncrasies that
drive us all a little bit nuts
but overall I mean he's a businessman he
knows how to make business happen I mean
we're we're talking the fact that we're
even talking sure some people are grumpy
and don't like what he tweets but you're
having conversations about it he's
waking up so he is making America great
again he's making America dare I say it
woke again Trump is making America great
again but the people around him are
trying to undermine him even in his own
party he can only do so much he's not a
dictator and this is where we have to
remember that
[Music]
[Applause]